Shoreline coming into view copy Striker
64 feet dry in 10 seconds
copy taking fire here Roger that we've
got RPGs down
there
[__] that was
close got a visual on the
target 5
Seconds stand for green down the ROP go
go go go
go
second squad on me to the Target
building the paring position let's
go there's the target building left side
door breach Stack
Up
blow the
charge breaching breaching go go go
clear Jackson take
point
[Music]
foree
Jackson draw a
[Music]
flashbang all call signs check the
bodies we need a positive ID on allad
negative ID over here sir no sign of
allad here sir HQ this is Red Dog Target
building is secure but we don't have
al-assad
over Roger that HQ out heads up I just
got word that alassad is broadcasting
half a click east of here at a TV
station out and take down the package
there move
out turn
down
down Target's in the
open contact up by that
car
we got a man now hostiles at that
door let's
go heads up friendlies at your six
en
contct
moving
fire hostile with
[Music]
RPG watch your fire Friendly's moving
up enemy troops in
the let me get run for
it
help open
fire
MO
let's go hostile burn those cinder
blocks over to the
east head up RPG
changing
go go go they're making a run for to the
east private take
cover Targets in the open
Southeast
enemy to the
east get some fire on those
guys watch your fire Friendly's moving
up
[Music]
down one
down
frag grenade
displ open fire
down let's
go
enemy hostile
down we got a man down
over near that F wall take them
out
reloading hostil over near that broken
wall on take them
out
Target building in
sight we've got the TV station locked
down and surrounded sir good get in
position to
breach do
it breaching breaching go go
go
supressing
fire one
down
[Music]
one down me follow
me
hostiles on the first
floor
out
en the
FL
got
man down over
here
enemy
[Applause]
suppress no
Target
enemy contact enemy Personnel on the The
Kill
dropped room clear move up allad should
be on the second
floor
yeah there goes our boys Ur
Ura hold your fire Friendly's coming
out no sign of alde Sir all right fall
in Marines stay
frosty
for
let
f
watch your six double
dog
spe
I think he's in there I hear him do
it clear
clear he's not here clear out
broadcast is
recorded yeah score one for military
intelligence Greggs turn that off that I
got something better anyway command this
is Red Dog TV station secure no sign of
aload the broadcast is a recording over
yeah
Ur Roger that command
out Marines rally up we got a new
assignment get your gear and get ready
to move out let's
[Music]
go